welcome to Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist and
tonight we're featuring our spate of
star talk all-stars led by Charles Liu a
friend and colleague and he's our geek
in chief with all things obscure and all
things geek especially as it relates to
Star Trek
this the 50th anniversary of the first
run of the series I'm old enough to
remember back then I remember sort of
celebrating what that world was little
discs that had data on it you put it in
a box and and information would come out
the other boxes where hot food would
come out instantly these things that
were we're in so far distant future you
you can barely imagine that they'll ever
occur
I also tried to add pretty strong grip
at the time I tried to grab people's
shoulders and paralyzed them the way
Spock did never worked so that's the
only part of that I didn't believe that
and the fact that doors would open
automatically I thought that was an
impossibly far prediction for the future
how could a door possibly know that
you're walking up to what he can never
know that I don't know so anyway y'all
have a good time tonight and start
stalkers all about learning science in
the context of pop culture that's
exactly what's going on so I leave you
in good hands I'm the older grass Tyson
signing off as always bidding you to
keep looking at I am Charles Lou I am an
astrophysics professor at the City
University of New York's College of
Staten Island and this is Startalk
Allstars live
this is our first live all-star show and
we're really excited to do it here I
cannot think of a better place to do it
than here at the Star Trek Mission New
York on the 50th anniversary of the
original series of Star Trek so thank
you all for being here
we can't wait to hear your questions and
your comments but right now let me bring
on our wonderful panel joining me
tonight first as my comedic co-host mr.
Chuck nice Chuck how are you buddy I am
well thank you thank you all for coming
it's a pleasure to have you all here and
we certainly appreciate Neil beaming in
from his Catskills hideaway Catskills
did you see all those trees in the
background I'm aware he was hidden yeah
there's only the Catskills could there
be that many trees absolutely there's
only two places in the world where there
could be that many trees the Catskills
is one of them Central Park is the other
maybe I was actually thinking Brooklyn
Park you know oh man okay
all right good well Chuck you are a
regular on Startalk we've done many
episodes together right and now we can
add all stars to that list absolutely
and it's very lot of fun right yeah okay
and you know you may not realize just
how much Trek
this gentleman has flowing in here well
we don't need to go into that yes we do
no yes we do yeah I'm a huge truck huge
trekker I've been a fan since as long as
I can remember and I I feel very good
that I'm in a place where I really don't
have to hide it you know it's very cool
yeah
you know we have two wonderful wonderful
science guests today the first one a
friend of mine whom I've known for many
years my first time sharing a microphone
with her from Columbia University
please welcome summer ash summer I know
is this great in addition to being on
Startalk snoo Allstars right and being a
host to Startalk all-star host you're
also an astrophysicist a director of
outreach for the Department of astronomy
at Columbia you're a freelance
journalist and in-house astrophysicist
for various cool television type things
a blogger a writer a Twitterer and you
totally understand what it means when we
fuse science with fiction and put it on
television I hope so yeah if it's not
you I can't imagine who else would do it
I'm so glad that you're here thank you
thank you and all the way from Canada
William Shatner's home country may we
add there is someone that I just met
today I'm very very very happy to
introduce you all to the person who
wrote this book Star Trek the official
guide to our universe and roof is akos
Andrew thank you so so much for coming
in the audience may or may not know
already that he is the night-sky guy you
are a TV broadcaster Andrew a syndicated
radio columnist you write the weekly
starstruck column for Nat Geo news and
since William Shatner wrote the foreword
to this book I think it is only fair
that you spend a moment describing what
is now the official guide to our
universe from the Star Trek perspective
let us know what you were trying to tell
us and then we'll get right into science
from that book and others go well yeah I
mean this is a labor of love for me I
mean I'm I am I'm in heaven with this
because I guess about ten years ten
years I've been working on this thing
two years of you know hard labor
watching Star Trek episode Oh hard labor
yeah movies you know scene by scene and
and you know what I've done here is
cherry-picked
episodes and movie scenes that really
reflect I think the the science of the
real science so well particularly
astronomical science my my kind of my
shtick is really showing people the
night sky that's what I've been doing
for I don't know about thirty years now
and since I was a little kid I've been
taking out a telescope and trying to get
people excited about the night sky you
know like grab them and say that would
do it what you just did there made me
want to grab a telescope and get out
there see that's what I'm talking about
that's so that's really what I love
about this and this book sort of I guess
what I like to call it is a Vulcan
mind-meld of two of my passions right
this stargazing and Star Trek coming
together in one one volume here you are
thoughts to my thoughts
Andrew threw a mine to his mind
where is yelling all c'n in the sky way
air is Cardassia Prime
where is Romulus where are these things
what is the answer to this question you
guys are the astrophysicists the answer
very basically is they're all in our
Milky Way galaxy exact right you heard
of the quadrants we live in which
quadrant alpha right and what is in the
Gamma Quadrant
the Dominion what is in the Delta
Quadrant
Voyager well no they came home they came
home they came the Borg mm-hmm so what
the heck is in the beta quadrant
does anybody know Rigel mm-hmm what are
these quadrants summer what is a
quadrant in a galaxy what is the
quadrants of our galaxy and why do we
only go in our galaxy why don't we go
beyond our galaxy because it's huge
compared to us is is it is it huge or is
it huge it depends on if Donald Trump if
Trump says it then it's huge well Bernie
also said you that's huge huge okay
that's the Brooklyn huge everybody
remember we are in New York after all
yes just tell us what is the size of our
galaxy and how come even with warp being
able to go up to nine point four when
we're trying to chase down the Borg in
the best of both worlds part two why
can't we exit our galaxy because we
can't even extra exit our solar system
yet the galaxy is so big it's at least a
hundred thousand light-years across
we're about two thirds of the way from
the Sun so each each half of it it's
about 50,000 light years and the
farthest that we've sent something right
now is one of the Voyager probes and
that is pretty much still around like
what twenty three hours away 23 light
hours of 23 light hours early a light
day Wow so 50,000 years not happening
and you know we could go up or down but
that's at least
that's on the scale of hundreds of light
years still so anytime first of all this
is just a fun fact point of information
anytime somebody shows you a picture of
the Milky Way it's not the Milky Way
it's a very nice artistic impression of
the Milky Way or it's an example of a
spiral galaxy and it's a picture of
another spiral galaxy that we can see
from our galaxy because we just can't
even send something out to take a
picture like that yeah you got to
remember that we are in the galaxy right
we are our view point here from Earth is
embedded within one of the arms the
humdrum suburbs of the galaxy right
because you sort of like a pinwheel
shape right so we're on one of the arms
that are spreading out from the central
bulge of the galaxy and we're embedded
there inside this this arm and our view
point really is only of a partial
partial of the galaxy I you know have we
actually seen the entire have we've been
able to map the entire galaxy
we haven't mapped every single star but
there are projects that are doing that
so there's Gaia and there's a new one
that I can't think of but Gaia is a
project that is trying to map hundreds
of thousands of stars in our galaxy and
we can take pictures so actually one
picture there's a one picture exception
and it's if you see a picture of the
Milky Way that looks like a strip that's
basically a panoramic that somebody has
taken from Earth and it looks like a
dusty plain with stars and can't see
through through the middle because
there's actually four as empty as space
is like the vacuum of space there's
still a lot of stuff in it and most of
it is gas and dust and it gets in the
way and it blocks starlight from us when
we're trying to look with optical
wavelengths like our eyes but the Milky
Way looks gorgeous from inside and I
have to say I think we're in the
prettiest suburb I've ever been in
mm-hmm so really we are like little tiny
fish in a vast ocean trying to map the
ocean we would be like Nemo trying to
find Dory
a lot of doors whither would not whither
without Sigourney Weaver's assistant
I just love the fact that you're mixing
mediums here so that's totally cool this
is what we do on Startalk we mix
everything so again
Nemo's finding Dory we are finding
Vulcan right we're looking for Cardassia
we're looking for Bajor all these
wonderful places that supposedly exist
and let me ask you the following if we
find them how will we know that they are
habitable what is the classification
Andrew how do we know something is a
world where actually there's something
never mind the the you know sort of
fictional way of saying Oh anything can
live anywhere right which is true but
non fictionally what do we need to look
for to make sure that life actually can
live somewhere on a planet well right
now one of the big criteria out there
that scientists use is looking at this
habitable zone around a star right so
this is what we affectionately call the
Goldilocks zone right it's not too hot
not too cold and on the surface of a
planet that is meaning that how far away
it is from its parent star so in terms
of liquid water being able to exist on
the surface so if if the planet would be
too far away from its parent star then
the water would basically freeze out on
the on the planet right so this most
recent discovery of Proxima be right
those of you heard this Proxima Centauri
is a probably the closest star to us a
mere four and a quarter or so
light-years away from Earth most recent
studies after literally decades of
people trying to find a planet around
there seem to suggest that there is a
planet there maybe one to two times the
mass of our planet orbiting in what we
might consider that habitable zone is
there life there I'd at this point I
don't think we can we can just it's
speculation right and we haven't really
we have to remember we haven't actually
observed the planet we haven't actually
directly imaged this planet or where
we're detecting the the effect that the
planet has on its parent star right in
this case we're looking at wobbles of
star because as planets go around their
post star the star actually ends up
wobbling because of the gravitational
pull and tug of that of those planets
and what's amazing is that we have such
exquisitely sensitive enough instruments
today that we can actually take those
wobbles measure them and and understand
like what how many planets are orbiting
around that star what their masses are
but to take it to the next level is what
I think would be really take is
understand like does it have an
atmosphere we know that it's one to take
in Proxima be a case we know that it's
one to two times the mass of the earth
and with our understanding of planetary
physics we think that it's a it's a it's
a rocky terrestrial type planet so has a
rocky surface someplace solid we could
land on right but does it have an
atmosphere we don't know that some are
how do we find out whether there's
atmospheres around other planets is
there a technique or techniques that
actually will give us that scientific
handle on whether there's gases
surrounding a planet yeah absolutely but
it requires a chance alignment because
so the method that Andrews talking about
is making use of this wobble but there's
another method that's called the transit
method which is when the star actually
goes sorry the planet goes in front of
the star and blocks the star's light
from us and we see a dip in that star's
light but that can only happen if you
know that solar system is in line with
our point of view and in theory the
stars and all of their potential planets
are in random directions from us so not
every star is gonna have its planets
going between us and them but when they
do the cool thing is that you can
actually monitor this star's light not
just the brightness but actually the
content of That star light the
metallicity sort of the spectrum of That
star what type of elements it has and
when the planet goes in front of it if
there's an atmosphere some of that light
goes through the planet's atmosphere and
then that changes what the star light
that we record is and we can subtract
one from the other because when the
planet goes
around the back of the star then that
signal goes away so you can figure out
what the atmosphere of that planet what
elements it's likely to have and Chuck
what would you do if you found a comedy
club on Proxima B I probably would make
sure they have air first yeah and then
maybe I might take a booking no the
first ever stand up in space Andrew you
had something else that on first I just
think that I'm so excited when I hear
that the idea of being able to have this
this chemical fingerprint of the
atmosphere because let's take that to
the next step if we could actually
detect the chemistry of an atmosphere of
an exoplanet we and we could tell what
what's there imagine if we found things
like methane or wait wait methane is
like cow farts why would I be excited
about finding cow farts cows are on the
planet oh it's also the funniest planet
let's be farts do make everything
funnier right just last night's it's
just a rule yeah okay exactly think of
it it's a potentially a sign of life
right potentially and are things like
chlorophyll hmm that would that be
interesting or how about greenhouse
gases or something like that so there
could be some very interesting findings
that could indicate very clearly that
there would potentially be life on these
planets wonderful and I just say that I
think it's really funny that the nearest
star to us is the one that took us so
long to find a planet around it's kind
of like when you're like looking for
your glasses and you can't find them and
they're on your head that is an
excellent point yeah no I think that's a
very good point sometimes the most
difficult things to find are the things
that are right near by but faint
approxima be you were there all the time
wait isn't there a song from the 1980s
like that the search is over you were
with me all the way
oh so you all are here thank you again
for joining us for our star talk
all-stars
first live show here at Star Trek
missions New York on the 50th
anniversary of this wonderful show Star
Trek and everything has come as a result
of it we're gonna zoom out a little bit
now and talk a little bit about some of
the science about the cosmos that shows
up you've heard now about the planets
about the earth about play now let me
ask you about the universe itself and
the first thing would ask you is warp
drive we have to know about warp drive
obviously the only reason you can get
from one place to another in any
reasonable time before the show gets
cancelled is warp drive right so how can
warp drive actually work does space-time
actually warp summer it does well
we've cleared that up now you can move
on with your lives because warp drive
works
she said space warps but can we use it
to drive because I want to mention a
Mexican physicist in a little while that
came up with something but please summer
first tell us how does space warp
exactly oh so space warps because like
Charles said space and time are kind of
this thing together and they're this
fabric of the universe we say but one of
the things look props yes so here's the
fabric of the universe and anything in
the universe that has mass is gonna warp
that fabric by the way the fabric of the
universe is a fine silk just in case you
were wondering it's about 70 cents a
yard yeah so things with mass actually
this is what Einstein theory of
gravitation tells us basically says that
because space and time are one an object
in in space time warps the area around
it and so that's why objects that get
within a certain distance
of something more massive than them will
fall towards it and eventually go into
orbit around it and so this will happen
I mean you're warping space right now
yes certain gravity on everybody else I
thought I suppose that thing as personal
space but none of us are big enough to
outweigh the other thing that's
attracting all of us which is the earth
beneath your feet
so it's warping space so we're stuck to
it all right well that's nice
I have here by the way my original
series era communicator right which we
will use as a prop to define gravity
okay so there is the communicator
warping space and time so why can't we
just use warp drive why can't we just
warp space and time in front of us and
before us and just drive on through I
don't know do you have enough mass just
sitting in your storage area to do that
so we need mass that's my Chuck I'm
fresh out of mass but thanks man Andrew
got any mass you can spare no I need or
everything I can get how much mass
precisely what we need to warp space in
time to such an extent that we actually
travel okay well let me tell you
something that somebody said in about
1994 there was a Mexican and physicist
named Miguel Alcubierre a Miguel
Alcubierre I wrote a paper speculating
that it might be possible for something
in a bubble to move faster than the
speed of light through space even though
you cannot move through space at or
faster than the speed of light if you
have any mass at all Alcubierre
hypothesized that the mathematical
equations of general relativity were
flexible enough that if you could create
an asymmetric bubble in space-time one
part compressed one part expanded it
would propel whatever's inside that
bubble forward through space at faster
than the speed of light or even slower
faster doesn't matter
right so that would be very cool yeah
does that make any scientific sense
Andrew it's theoretically possible but
can we actually build a spaceship that
would have enough power generate enough
power to do that bend space-time well
apparently all we need is some
antimatter and a Delicia mystile right
right that's all you need mm hmm is that
a nice thing to do but in in true
physics how much mass would be necessary
would would a planet-sized object be
enough to do that kind of warping of
space-time Charles I'm an astronomer not
a physicist that was very bones McCoy of
you Jarret actually do you all know the
difference between an astronomer and
astrophysicist right when I am on an
airplane and someone sits down next to
me and says hey so what do you do for a
living if I want to speak with this
person I say I'm an astronomer and if I
would rather be quiet and not speak with
a person I say I'm an astrophysicist
yeah that works every time but I know
that you have a specialty in radio
astronomy summary you understand things
that produce radio waves out in the
universe coolest they are cool can you
give us a sense of say two or three such
things that we have run into or by we I
mean the enterprise X a/b c/d
okay yeah we'll stop there yeah well
stars give off radio waves actually
really yeah I mean there's just not the
brightest in the sky but like our Sun so
any given star is gonna show up if you
look at it with a radio type of
telescope okay um and also I just want
to clarify because this can be a source
of misconception radio even the radio
that most of us don't have anymore we
have wireless we have Spotify and
Pandora but the radio in your car the
radio your old
boombox for those of us that know what
those are
that radios light actually so your radio
is picking up a light signal that's in
radio frequencies and then it's turning
it into sound that comes out of the
speakers so when we talk about the radio
universe we're not talking about picking
up I mean we can pick up sound signs
sorry signals that we can turn into
sound
but radio astronomy is looking at things
with radio telescopes and you can see
the coolest types of lights so you can
see supermassive black holes and they
look nothing like an actual galaxy so
you can see a pretty picture of a spiral
galaxy and then you put on your radio
glasses and it looks like giant Jets
just spewing out into space and shooting
particles and hot plasma out there too
like scales ten times the size of the
galaxy but can you pick up a classic
rock station yes how about some classic
extra galactic fm how about some classic
surfer punk while you are driving an old
starship through a whole bunch of drones
that are heading toward a really really
oddly gravitational Space Station how
real was that how possible is it for
those of you who haven't seen the most
recent Star Trek movie trailer 2016
oh no oh don't worry we haven't given up
anything significant yet yeah okay by
the way just because you should have
seen it by now Picard ends up pregnant
[Laughter]
right so that is a very interesting
science that was shown in that
particular space station right Andrew if
you saw that movie you saw that people
are walking up and down sideways left
and right and so on was that some weird
artificial gravity effect where can that
actually happen in real physics that's a
good question well ask the non physicist
astronomer person right come on summer
you're a physicist as much as I am so
actually I
did not see it Oh what I can't know
about any magic artificial gravity
imagine a smorgasbord of weird things
like going this way your escalator is
going this way like an S cheryan
painting and yet your hand is drawing
your other hand while your brain is up
here and the environmental system is
spewing out this black stuff okay or not
were you on anything when you were
watching well the popcorn butter was
pretty darn amazing I have to say it's
true but yes tell us about artificial
gravity is there actually physics -
artificial gravity I believe there is so
in some good examples of it are in 2001
hmm
the spinning Space Station so the fact
is that once you're spinning the you're
forced away from the center of rotation
and so you can put the wall there that
then becomes your floor dude and I think
it was also in Elysium dude and it was
in interstellar um and so an
interstellar they were like floating
through the space station see the
gravity change
when they were going from let the woman
finish come on man we need some
atmosphere so is there a way to make
artificial gravity the way you see a
portray the most sci-fi without the
spinning so the physics of the spinning
of course that makes sense with the
student reputable force but when you see
a ship and it's just traveling and
everyone is just not floating is there a
way to feasibly create that environment
no I am so sorry I questioned well okay
I would love to have that well well what
about gravitational waves that's a whole
different ballgame yeah cuz we were
talking about like warping space-time
right yeah and recently a very very big
deal was made of gravitational waves can
we not just um surf the long a
gravitational wave and actually like
travel where we have that how does that
work actually what I would really like
to get are the boots that Chatam
Channing Tatum had in madera sending
because as he described it they they
changed differential equation slips so
you can surf them which what's total
sense right well it does to me
[Laughter]
gravitational waves are so Charles had
this fabric of space-time right can I go
to and gravitational waves are basically
when there are two massive things that
end up merging two black holes in this
case so two black holes one was they
were roughly both thirty masses one was
a little higher one was a little lower
many times the mass of the Sun yes
exactly sorry thirty times the mass of
our Sun and they were orbiting each
other because actually most stars exist
in binary systems our Sun is kind of an
exception but we think two-thirds of the
stars in the galaxy are roughly that I'm
not sure if that's changed but binaries
and a lot of times they they can involve
in lockstep or they can involve one
ahead of the other but you can actually
get a case of where you have two black
holes there was as the result of a
binary at the end of there
and they are warping space-time and
they're actually losing energy so
they're falling towards each other and
then eventually they speed up speed up
speed up swept and then merge and then
all of space-time goes rippling out kind
of like somebody threw a massive rock in
a pond and so that ripple went through
the earth and it was detected by two
different observatories and when I say
observatories in this case the these are
not types of light whatsoever
this is space actually stretching so
these observatories LIGO that's called
laser interferometer gravitational
observatory are two two arms that are
four kilometers long and at each end of
each arm is a mirror and in the middle
there's a couple different beam
splitters and a laser and the laser is
basically being split down each arm and
bounces back off those mirrors and it's
set so that when the light comes back it
looks like everything's perfect they're
exactly the same length but a
gravitational wave passes through and
one of those arms gets a little bit
longer and then the light looks funny
and the scientists can do the math and
they can back that out this happened and
the lengths that one of those arms
stretched was the width of a proton Wow
so and we detected that that's we're
good
that's a millionth millionth of a
billionth of an inch on something that's
more than 2 miles long and it was able
to be measured this is what your tax
dollars are paying for ladies and
gentlemen and how cool is it that from
that tiny tiny tiny little length we're
like oh that's the black hole this big
and a black hole this big and they're
about in that direction and they totally
collided because it's amazing Andrew
where is the nearest black hole to us oh
my gosh well there's there's a few
there's a few candidates and it's a very
controversial exactly how far away but
they're one of them
is near Sajid in the Sagittarius
constellation uh-huh so you would be
right now at this time of the year it's
something that you would be locating in
the southern sky late at night about a
few couple hours after the Sun has set
so you'd be looking low from here in New
York and below in the southern horizon
you try to get out of the city of course
you want to see the and but and you'd be
able to see and from a dark location
maybe we are aware Neil is in kills me
and there is one that's a that's about
6,000 light light-years away
so what's neat is to think that when we
are examining these objects right
everything in space is so far away we
measure we use the measure of
light-years because that's how when we
say something 6,000 light-years away
means that light has taken six thousand
years to reach us here on earth so we're
observing that object as it appeared six
thousand years ago but of course in
terms of black holes and lifetime of
stars they're there their lives are
measured in in in hundreds of millions
to billions of years so changes are not
really that obvious unless we really get
very exquisitely sensitive instruments
right yeah oh it's wonderful I love
babies by the way it is totally okay for
that wonderful child to be making those
noises are you doing a Donald Trump
right now what the hell she believed
yeah I love babies get it out of here
like do not bring bring the baby up
later I want to give it a hello um I
think one of the great things this is
not exactly science but I think one of
the great things about about Star Trek
was in fact it's family friendliness
right that there were actually children
on the enterprise-d and things like that
even though stodgy old picard was like
new but III think it's a I think it's a
great thing I'm really really a big fan
of that what are you talking about I
loved Engine cross off
yes he was a little child wasn't either
mhm yes but yeah I think that's that's
one of the ways you know and and of
course there are panels here this
weekend about the psychology and the
sociology of Star Trek and how things
have changed as well
and I think maybe one of the things that
has really helped is now there are
children and workplaces and maybe that's
because of the enterprise-d right
wouldn't that be cool child labor you're
blaming on the enterprise oh my god hey
Apple it's ok have you seen the latest
Star Trek you get in there and make that
phone young man ok so let me just bring
up two more things from the Star Trek
episodes and then what I'd love to do is
for people to to ask some questions of
us things that we can answer from you
about the science that has shown up in
Star Trek a couple of times there's some
microphones over here and over there so
if you'd like to come up at some point
and as your been modifying or thinking
about whether we're talking about it
here or whether you had this question in
your mind for a long time
and I just want to ask you two first
Andrew then summer about two things that
were mentioned in Star Trek The Next
Generation which I still don't really
know that much about okay so Andrew
we'll start with you starting first in
the Star Trek the motion picture and the
word wormhole was mentioned right what
the heck is a wormhole and then of
course Star Trek Voyager is all about
wormholes right it's like everything is
a wormhole what the heck is a wormhole
is there actually a scientific thing
called a wormhole that actually exists I
believe that theoretically right summer
there is and some are you maybe you can
elaborate but it's a it's like two black
holes that are connected I believe in in
in warping of space and time and there's
this bridge that sort of allows you to
travel very large distances very quickly
yeah so physically it doesn't exist but
theoretically it's possible is that what
you're saying yeah and we haven't found
any any sign of a wormhole no can I use
one of your paper you can look it up oh
yes please and I use your pencil Oh
total oh here we go this is okay
break up space-time again right let's
just say earth and now we'll say volka
drama yeah
Vulcan welcome thank you ok alright
earth and Vulcan we want to get from
here to here this way we're all gonna
die our next generations gonna die the
generation after that it'll be who knows
how long but the secret way is this way
Wow boom that was my paper dude wormhole
oh man that's the theory but that's what
it allows you to do it allows you to not
go the long way but to go the short way
Wow but yeah and how about a hand for
our very expensive visual effects here
it starts off we spare no expense
he's paper and a pen science it just
seems to me that it's a lot easier for
us to bend ourselves and to bend
space-time right but you know I'm just a
physicist astrophysicist astronomer you
know what do I know I just just my
thought okay all right and let me ask
you one thing and let's start taking
some questions arise so please start
coming up let me ask you the following
question in the episode of the next
generation entitled of the laws the
enterprise is almost sucked into a
cosmic string later later on in the
series in these episode disaster the
enterprise runs into a quantum filament
and then as do you all know right
counselor Troi's first to assume the
bridge and then O'Brien is saying we ran
into a quantum filament she says oh so
that's like a cosmic string and then oh
resin oh that's a totally different
phenomena was I good that was okay right
yeah so what is a quantum filament and
are they actually different things do
they actually exist I have no idea but
the word quantum to me means really tiny
yeah so a big ship running into
something really tiny doesn't seem like
a problem well my understanding is that
they're just possibly remnants of the
Big Bang when the universe was very
small there was an imperfection in the
actual expansion that
universe at the moment of inflation or
just after the Big Bang
then magnified any imperfections that
were tiny and turned them gigantic but I
do not know so if any of you out there
those of you who are in line waiting to
ask questions you know the difference
between a quantum filament and a cosmic
string please inform us all and let's
write a paper together thank you so so
much
okay so we are ready here on Startalk
all stars live to take questions from
the audience here at Star Trek missions
New York the 50th anniversary it is a
tremendous pleasure to be here let's
start over here yes please what is your
question and please feel free to move
the microphone that will make it easy
for you to use yes I wanted to know if
it's true that in the future the
transporter technology will become real
great question Andrew you want to take a
crack at that and then Chuck I want you
to take a crack at that afterwards I can
tell you I would never want to be in a
transporter why I think that I learned I
just like even if they develop that I
would not go I'm like I'm like McCoy I
just hate those things I'll be damned if
I get near molecular the the thing about
transporters which I would say is that
you have to get every single subatomic
particle in its exact quantum state
completely replicated right but there is
this thing called the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle in quantum
mechanics which means that if you take a
particle from one location and move it
to another there is a certain amount of
you don't know what's gonna happen no
matter what so I personally think it
would be a great idea to have a third
head okay but I don't know that my hands
would want to have become heads if I get
transported so until we can solve the
uncertainty question right and you've
heard like oh the highs of the UH the
Heisenberg compensators are not in flux
we don't know what's going on and boom
Picard becomes a kid right you've seen
that kind of thing happening that's a
very good question so at this moment I
would say so the answer is probably not
no no okay thank you for my favorite
exam
transporter going wrong is in space
balls space balls Oh No she's still
enjoying the moment yes thank you yes
your question please or comment hi how
you doing very well thank you so my
question is you mentioned earlier about
the Voyager probe that was the farthest
thing that we've sent out in space so
far and I know that the motion picture
feature is you know Voyager but my
question is about the real one where
how far out can it go and still be able
to reach earth and will will be able to
be in contact with it and receive signal
and how do we receive the signal in the
first place oh that's a great question
summer do you know that great question
yes well it's got a radio transmitter on
it it's actually not we can't actually
send signals to it to tell it to do
things anymore because it's just it's
it's running on batteries it's too far
from the Sun for any solar power so it's
just gonna go until the batteries go and
I believe there was either a malfunction
or the batteries went on Voyager 2
already because we're out I do much with
that one yeah um I mean it can go
forever until it hits something which
it's so small compared to things that's
very unlikely
and so it's kind of pinging us and it
did it can ping us enough and tell us
the composition of the space around it I
believe because that's how we had the
most recent news about it leaving the
Sun's magnetosphere the sun's solar
influence but not the gravitational
influence so there's a hilarious comic
does anybody know xkcd no yeah how do I
not know it one of the best ones is how
many times has Voyager left the solar
system because there's so many different
ways to define the edge of the solar
system and also Voyager has sort of gone
through the a bunch of different
transitional phases that we've never
been sure like oh is this it is this it
is this it and so now I think we think
that it's confident that it's outside
the magnetosphere but it's still not
outside the solar system it is still
gonna go it still hasn't passed the Oort
cloud like that's hundreds of years away
andr do you know how long the batteries
will last I know that we receive the
signals using our deep space network
active decay right that's it's being
powered by radioactive Jets right
alright so I thought they were
Energizer's yeah yeah I think it's
coming close to the end I mean there may
be another decade so they're 40 years
out now so maybe 10 more years I believe
the radio thermal isotopic
thermoelectric generators were supposed
to last 20 years and it's already after
40 so we got our money's worth
apparently NASA does build them like
they used to right thank you very much
for your question thank you and I just
want to add to the Deep Space Network
because if you haven't seen it you
should google it and JPL there's a guy
at JPL who made a jet propulsion lab
it's propulsion laboratory who made a
visualization that's actually up on the
screens in the Mission Control room at
JPL and it has the Deep Space Network
antennas that are on the ground and it
can show you which antenna is talking to
which space probe and it shows you
whether it's talking we're talking to it
or it's talking to us and if it's
sending data or we're sending data it's
kind of the coolest thing out there I
know that the Voyager signal is now
weaker than one ten billionth of a watt
by the time it gets to the earth so it's
a pretty amazing technology
yes go ahead we talked a little bit
about lasers already yes using lasers
for my new tasks whether it be a laser
pointer or whether it be surgery etc yes
how about phasers is there any
scientific ability to take lasers or
something to that extent
and have them impact and cause damage to
something possibly the size of this
building the island of Manhattan etc are
you an evil genius laughs just looking
for ideas that's a great question one
thing that I'm pretty sure is gonna
happen is that phasers will not evolve
from lasers because lasers are a
specific kind of coherent light beam and
you're exactly right there they're micro
type things they're very precise whereas
phasers clearly are like you know
Deathrays of the olden days right but
are there beams are there energy beams
that can be harnessed in that way to
cause damage on a physical level summer
do you know Andrew do you have any ideas
military DARPA I think are working on
laser based weapon mm-hmm
but the lasers that I add more interest
as the idea of communication
extraterrestrial communication using
laser beams for that that's their
searches now aren't there I think you
looking at lasers powerful lasers
powerful enough to to cross the cosmos
and be able to communicate so wonderful
there's also a science about using
lasers to either cloak your transit
signal or make it so it's clearly
artificial and doesn't look like
realistic so you can announce your
presence if another planet was watching
you transit
wonderful thank you we have so many
people who have questions let's let's
get as many of them as we can into that
is wonderful yes sir over here and
lasers is propulsion - oh yes that's
true the pressure of the light can
actually push something forward in the
in in the no friction' environment of
space that's right which actually would
cause the problem if part of my next
question we're actually true whenever
they go through an asteroid field in
Star Trek wars in cosmos even there was
show the asteroids really really close
together and that's something that's
bothered me for a long time because it's
just not true
I was wondering from the panelists
what's something from Star Trek or
related that has bothered you that's
really kind of scientifically inaccurate
but makes for better writing oh great
question okay can I just go first
yes okay do it in the next generation
episode starship mine at the beginning
of the episode yeah Captain's Log
whatever whatever whatever you know the
enterprise is at the space station
so that it can have its excess baryons
removed okay and baryons are protons and
neutrons so if you're removing the
baryons everything's gone everything
well that's why if you get
and the baryon field you die I know
right but that was just so funny I saw
them's like removing excess baryons from
the ship and I was like look that the
person I was watching the show with
together at the time who happened to be
an astrophysicist who got his degree
from MIT we stared at each other and we
died and my poor wife was like you guys
are morons that's my favorite story
thank you
anybody well so I have one from the
original series they because I just
re-watched it again recently the episode
nomads where there is a space probe yes
that sort of has been altered in its
mission but they bring in a board and
they are trying to communicate with it
and so Kirk says if I show you like our
star maps you know but you you can see
where we're from and the star map was
literally a poorly drawn version of our
solar system that's not gonna tell you
anything about where we're located
somebody got that matter right okay yeah
I got it you got it okay because it's
from that episode exactly yeah okay and
so instead though what they could do
speaking of Voyager is that they could
have used the Pulsar map which obviously
had not been created at that time but
the Pulsar map that's on the Voyager
record that's on the Voyager probes is
there to show where earth is in relation
to the pulsars in our neighborhood of
our galaxy because the pulsars have such
precise timing that another civilization
should be able to also have observed
some of them and then like kind of
triangulate eventually that's why that
was put on the plaque exactly yeah the
golden records they here we are how they
can find us please find us take our
natural resources that's a great idea
hey you alien life-form clearly superior
to us because you can get to us why does
he come on over yes
and so in 1977 in my home state of Ohio
the WoW signal was recorded
curious I mean it sounds like since it
was discovered there's really no
consensus of what it actually was and
I'm curious if you guys have an opinion
on that or what your what your thoughts
has there been any advanced the
literature for the WoW signal yeah
there's been recently ice I remember in
the last couple of years that they think
it might have been a satellite or
something a signal signal bouncing off
us uh so it's more of a terrestrial
origin that kind of reminds me of what
we just heard in the news with the other
alien signal right yeah yeah from the
Hercules constellation the the the
planet about ninety four light-years
away supposedly it's turning out that
the latest information from the Russian
Academy they put out a statement I think
just a few days ago saying that they
think it's terrestrial in origin
unfortunately so all our prey
sorry yes we're still not quite there
yet right Chuck we just need a little
more time to prove that they are out
there and then well they're out there
you know they're just they're just
hiding that's all you sure I'm positive
I've spoken to them oh that's all we
need that's another episode I think
we're good with that thank you very much
yes question good evening hi there was
an episode of next generation yes that
dealt with the idea that using warp
drive repeatedly in the same area of
space might cause a rupture which is
kind of an obviously a comment on
environmentalism but in Star Trek yes
indeed obviously that idea would be so
far ahead of us to even think about but
is there any way in which
environmentalism in our interaction with
space has come up in any of the
technologies and space exploration thing
oh I I will say that when the Deep
Impact mission was going to launch a
chunk of metal into a comet
tempel-tuttle I think it was yeah that's
and then there was somebody that tried
to sue NASA saying that we were messing
up the environment the the vibes of the
universe by messing up that particular
thing I don't know that did anything
come out of that no the person actually
ran out of marijuana and
gave up on the case but there is the
idea forward contamination for planetary
missions oh that's a big issue right
that's a bean point you know you get
some microbes hitching a ride on one of
our spacecrafts and we send it to say
Mars right this is a big thing of
sending our our little germs there and
then how do we detect life for real on
these planets if we're contaminating the
Cassini spacecraft when its mission ends
where was it's not going to go just let
it go right now they will not be
pollution instead because they don't
want to contaminate Europa right sorry
Enceladus Enceladus but do you know
they're doing the same thing with Juno
around Jupiter that when it's done
they're plowing it into Jupiter to not
contaminate Europa so the answer is I
guess we are environmentally aware of
the solar system and maybe the universe
thank you
there's a NASA office called the office
of planetary protection hey hey hey all
right yes I'm curious to hear your
theory you know science fiction a first
contact was a realistic thing to happen
in our lifetime how would you imagine
that would play out what type of
intelligence would we be dealing with
and what would it take on Aaron to be
able to really conceptually establish
communication Wow
I just want to tell you that on April
5th 2063 I will be in Montana okay I'm
just telling you that it's gonna be a
great vacation we're gonna drive out
there enjoy Yellowstone whatever and
then on April 5th I'm just gonna stand
there and I'm just gonna stand there and
I bet you you all will stand there with
me right April 5th 2063 yeah actually is
there a realistic scientific way to deal
with first contact well I think there's
a protocol that they've put together Oh
for that and you know yeah that's right
of how we would go about doing that
but it's very controversial too because
do we want to announce like if we and
you have to remember if we do get a
signal let's say we're supposing we're
looking at radio signals now how far
away these are I mean it's it will
it's more more more likely a one-way
conversation I mean they're gonna go
high and that may take what if it's 500
light years away it'll take us to say hi
that's another 500 it's like what kind
of conversation can we worst remote
delay ever wow that's a big issue right
yeah in terms of communicating so so yes
a job a guy at SETI has that's called
like director sir magician of message
composition oh yeah are you looking for
a job
he's also deciding what we're gonna say
that's great I hope he says no no no but
you know thank you great question yes so
there was an episode of Voyager I think
it was either the second or third
episode where the Voyager crew finds
himself in this time loop and they
actually see and receive a transmission
from themselves about like a couple of
hours in the future yes and I was
wondering how scientific is that
phenomenon is that based on a real
theory is that complete TV that's a
great question
your ears are awesome by the way well
done um here's what I know about that
and then please add in if you understand
when radio signals get sent out they get
scattered all over the place
right and if you have an appropriate
environmental situation like a highly
ionized cloud of gas or something it is
possible to reflect some of that off of
that and come back alright there is a
time delay that happens as well for
example around supermassive black holes
if you have a kind of a graphite dust or
other kind of dust that has a special
orientation to it and then you have
magnetic fields that hold that
orientation they almost act like a side
mirror sort of like spider-man's you
know vision thing on the side so the
light goes to you gets to you first and
the light going out sideways bounces off
and then
to you later right that's a time delay
thing and that's also this light is
polarized so you can see all kinds of
neat things that that are unusual so
there is possible to get multiple
signals like from various physical
sources of doing that that particular
episode might have had more details than
that is there anything that you'd like
to add to what I just said in terms of
getting multiple signals or getting a
time delay and what we had in the past I
think we're pretty good Chuck yeah I
think you covered it I'm gonna go with
what he said okay thank you very much
yes compared to some of the other ones
no no question is too simple
we love this can you guys explain
stardates stardates
star date come on official guy do well
you know from my book too you know I was
looking at star dates and I I would I
was confounded with how they came up
with it it's all over the place and the
last I found the most sense in this in
the reboot series it was very simple
it's the year and thought the day the
day the the date of the year of the the
number of the day of the year so in 2016
dot 200 and you know 24 or something
like that for the day of the the year
itself but it's based on the you know
yeah because the day of the year would
have to be based on a revolution around
our sauna so it would be yes so it's the
date but based on just don't say May or
June but but my guess is that all had to
be retroactive Lee continued read
chondrite to make it work because I have
no idea how they work either I think
it's just stuff people saying stuff
which is really cool so we we are
basically out of time but but I want to
get to all your questions so so let's
get to all the questions that are in
line and and then we will call it a a
show does that sound like fun okay thank
you all really we very much appreciate
if you have to go you know you've really
got to catch them
last 45 minutes of Star Trek to the
Wrath of Khan 4k I completely understand
but we've got some great questions
coming up and we're gonna finish this up
coming up here yes please go ahead
question I'm not at all figley impaired
no you're not no no no no no no no no
remember I'm a professor I have to tell
you this nobody is scientifically
impaired science is beautiful and it's
wonderful and you are all good at it
it's all a matter of whether you've got
the training to write it down it's like
you know I could be Swahili impaired
right because I don't speak it but
that's not because I can't do it it's
just because I haven't done it yet
that's where you are now in life always
remember that okay always remember that
thank you please ask you a question
thank you
I've always been curious in any way
shape or form can the shuttle's going up
or rockets going up mess with the
weather
Oh happens I tend to notice that's just
me when a shuttle used to go up in
Florida rocket we had some weird weather
so I always wonder like okay are they
here thing you know that's a great
question Andrew do you have any insight
on that nope okay so I don't think that
there is a cause of causal effect there
could be a correlation but correlation
does not equal causation and probably
weird weather you're more prone to
notice and a shuttle is something you're
also more prone to notice so it just
might be sort of observational bias but
there are people that do study sort of
rocket plumes and they you know the
exhaust of rockets and what they do to
the atmosphere but it's a very local
phenomenon and you know they dissipate
within a certain amount of time and
probably nothing on the scale that could
could really affect strong weather
patterns okay yeah no problem educated
guess that that's very likely to be true
and and because clouds formed by
nucleating around things you can imagine
that an exhaust plume could cause clouds
to nucleate right so locally as
says it may actually have a good effect
so that's a very good question see it's
not at all not at all bad question now
go ahead and write your first science
book here let me let me let me mention a
couple of science books while we're at
it we have to show this is available
downstairs in the exhibit hall so please
remember that this is Andrews book
StarTrek the official guide to our
universe okay and this is Startalk the
book with Neil deGrasse Tyson alright
and this will be available also
downstairs and feel free to enjoy these
these and many of the questions that
we've had are in these books and we're
here all day right yeah okay
so let's get to the rest of the
questions please your question okay
so subspace is largely a fictional
concept yes very interesting hypothesis
that subspace discrete subspace layers
are represented by the work function
number so that you reach a threshold and
then continue to the next layer and the
energy goes up like like the seven
layers of hell we've already kind of
covered like going through wormholes and
warp drive so I was thinking how did how
would they justify that within the idea
of subspace communication because in
theory it which would take a long time
for the signal to go and then to get a
reply you know Picard to be sitting
there waiting for a reply to happen yeah
they kind of use the narrative device to
speed up the production of having
instantaneous communication so how would
subspace communication work in a more
practical standpoint if you all don't
and you want to crack about something
okay subspace if it exists and is
basically our space-time or some version
of our space-time right because string
theory does allow for the existence of
other space times in parallel with ours
if you are going through these
boundaries that get us from one
space-time to another through say
membranes or some other kind of string
or structures supersymmetry or something
like that
each membrane has its own threshold but
those thresholds we have no idea if
there's actually any physics involved
with them do they have actually an
entropic barrier are they just
so separated that they never come across
or are they instantaneous under the
right circumstances so in that kind of
context I can see that there could be an
effect but there doesn't have to be
right and then the issue of total
internal reflection or partial
reflection between layers if that's how
happens but this is something that I
really don't have a good answer to but
that's a great question though yeah
because we're thinking about the distri
it's played a big role in Star Trek
allows us to see a wonderful you know
episode yes out and allows those stories
to move forward I mean that's the same
idea with transport or system the warp
drive it allows us to have these
wonderful stories play out mm-hmm mm-hmm
very true and and that's why we're all
here right yes question over here I love
your hat by the way I don't know if
there's a Pikachu Trek coming up but I
sure hope it is soon gotta catch them
all out of all the ways that they've
traveled in Star Trek what's your
favorite way like what way would you
choose and why great Chuck what way
would you like to travel you know
unfortunately there's no buses in space
no I mean I to be honest I think we need
to be able to travel at warp speed would
be just unbelievable you know to be in
that position I mean just to be able
because the bridge has a visual so can
you imagine the visual of traveling
faster than the speed of light and what
that would look like as you're sitting
on the bridge of a ship watching that go
by you
I don't smoke marijuana but I am puffing
a I'm puffing away while that's
happening just to trip out on that okay
cuz that's got to be very very trippy
yeah if you're faster than the speed of
light though all the lights behind you
well you know what
now you just ruined my whole thing sorry
Oh Andrew you have a favorite travel guy
I agree I was gonna say warp because for
me as a stargazer
you know everything is remote write
everything up in the night sky are these
little points of light and you know I
take my telescope and no matter how big
of a telescope I get I'm still remote
and then to have this capability to go
to these places and have ringside seats
you know this is what I love about Star
Trek since I've been a little kid is
Star Trek allows me as a space geek to
get these ringside seats that are
otherwise impossible and with today's
technology right the film technology we
have these hyper realistic visions of
space and just like with the new movie I
mean obviously you know there's some
some elements that are go well that's
not realistic or something but it allows
me like the the the portraits of nebula
for instance you know even going back to
like Wrath of Khan and the Mutara nebula
that has stayed with that is my favorite
nebula it is it's harren of you and by
the way that's kind of mall on the Orion
the great Orion Nebula which you can see
every winter it's my I told them I gotta
have that because it's beautiful and it
really does look beautiful I mean look
at the Hubble Space Telescope a so well
and they play an integral role in many
Star Trek episodes and so having warp
speed to get there and to just hang out
and see these these objects would be
awesome wonderful summer oh I just like
the part of the hanging out like I would
just sit next to a window of any ship
and just look out because that's like my
favorite thing to do if I can go to a
dark sky it's just sort of sit
underneath it and just look at it
my favorite way of travel would be to go
through the wormhole right next to deep
space 9
and to go to the Gamma Quadrant and
watch all those swirly things go around
that would be my favorite way to travel
think of all the things you could
explore things that we that we would not
be able to see otherwise without having
that transports absolutely so this is
what I'm gonna do everybody I did say
we're gonna answer all
questions and we are going to answer
your questions but what we're gonna do
right now then is we're gonna do two
things the first thing we're gonna do is
do a an ending of the show for the
podcast right now while everyone's here
like big loud clap okay and then we're
gonna get your questions and we're gonna
do it a second time afterwards sound
good all right this is how we're gonna
make this happen ready so this has been
Startalk Allstars
you can watch this entire episode
commercial-free on Startalk all-access
summer ash thank you and Rufus acres
Thank You Chuck nice thank you so much
I'm Charles little enjoy the universe
everyone thank you so much
[Music]
that was awesome that was awesome well
done okay let's answer these questions
and then let's do a real wrap-up okay
but I know people need to go and I want
to thank you all for staying it's really
really been such a great great time and
anyone else wants to move closer so that
your applause is louder later please
feel free to do that too okay
yes go ahead oh wait over here yes
please go ahead so the the gaudi locked
zone is that unnecessarily living into
our choices of candidates for possible
life given our observations with sea
vents and the moons out in Jupiter and
Saturn and how much gravitational energy
that's possibly biologically you know
useful usable are we limited by just
focusing on Sun energy on the surface
and the atmosphere Andrew brain do you
have a answer to that then summer can
follow up so in terms of what we're you
mean look searching for life where the
wife could be because we have the tubes
down in the ocean they get no Sun energy
to speak of right and that could be
happening out on the exactly and that's
yeah and and that's something the
ability to see exomoons not EXO plan the
moons of exoplanets is something that I
think we're just starting to that's
really a big endeavor there's a race
around the world amongst astronomers to
really be able to see it we
theoretically think just like we thought
exoplanets were around you know you know
the time when Star Trek started it was a
theory but now you know it's really but
the moons you know around say Jupiter or
Saturn but with the high density of
binary stars you have all that gravity
is energy does that possibly a better
way to focus yeah I think I think what
Andrew saying is that we sort of have to
start with what we can do and so
basically what we can do now is see
planets around stars and figure out how
far away they are and then start
figuring out if they have an atmosphere
and if they're in a habitable zone but
you're completely right that as far as
the most likely place in our solar
system for finding life signs of life
right now it's probably a Europa
and then maybe also Enceladus and so
that shows us that once we are able to
see learn more about these other solar
systems that then we can start thinking
about EXO moons and also just extreme
environments in general because I
totally agree baby yeah thank you
there's actually an astronomer at
Columbia right now David kipping who
came from Harvard and he's originally
from England and he does exome ins so
he's he's he's going for it
yes go ahead I have a simple question
what is the Galactic barrier the
galactic barrier which theoretically
happened in a couple of episodes and
then also at the in the fifth movie the
final frontier the the one we owe at all
well never mind that galactic barrier
was supposedly something that we could
not penetrate unless we had some sort of
tremendous magical energetic push
through that barrier is there's anything
physical to that barrier what did that
actually come from something that might
be physically true and we shake it only
thing the only thing that I've come
across is the the fact that there's a
supermassive black hole at the center of
our galaxy just like it exists and
probably most galaxies that we see mmm
these monster black holes that measure
you know billions of times the mass of
our Sun and they belch out amended
tremendous amounts of radiations right
all kinds of radiation so there's those
kind of things but I don't think there's
any barrier per se right Chuck no
barriers not in my life I'm barrier-free
quite frankly thank you very much
yes all right I have a fun question good
what emerging technology or scientific
principle would you like to see explored
in Star Trek discovery when the new
series oh wow what a great question
right question all right summer you're
thinking hard okay we'll give Andrew
this first one I like medical stuff
that's such a hot topic today is all you
know teak let's see where we could go
with what McCoy had right
you know in the tricorder and stuff and
we're living in in a time where we have
wrist-worn medical devices right and
there's this promise of being you know
non-intrusive medical tests you know
I've heard now there's a work on even
doing like a glucose monitoring without
any Wow diabetics a lot of said oh I
want to see that that's great yeah Chuck
you know uh III kind of like the medical
thing too I mean when you think about it
even it's all in the news now but when
you think about the EpiPen and its
delivery system the first time we saw
that was in the hypo with bones where he
would just and was just make that and I
was like as a kid I felt like man if
only it were that easy
just to get a needle like that would be
awesome so you know yeah it's a pretty
cool thing I was thinking maybe like 3d
printing because that's sort of
something that's already like implied in
in that universe replicator but it's
sort of just like magically happens but
I think that we're getting towards some
of that you know the very edge of the
beginning of that and even there's a 3d
printer on the space station and so the
astronauts can print a tool if they need
it or if something breaks it's kind of
amazing maybe one day they'll be able to
walk up and go tea Earl Grey hot oh wait
thank you very much thank you yes
I have two questions about gravitons
graviton zu you're not talking about
that old 1970s Marvel super villain
right graviton no not that guy
okay all right as far as I understand it
gravity should have a particle yes and
would two things if when we find it for
the artificial gravity on the ship could
they be manipulating gravitons to to
keep them down and second if we do find
it could we maybe make a warp field sort
of based on graviton so we don't need we
could just create and so instead of mass
you would manipulate the gravitons to
create that bubble you were talking
about I'll just put a little bit of a
particle physics background on that
question and then I would love for
summer to give this a shot
I get the easy part obviously so
according to the current model of
particle physics there are four kinds of
what are called bosons these are the
things that carry force they mediate
between the four forces of the universe
the strong nuclear force has something
called a gluon the electromagnetic force
has something called a photon and the
weak nuclear force has something called
the intermediate vector bosons the W and
Z particles is what they are and for
gravity their thus should be a thing
another particle because it's a four
students called the graviton but the
graviton has never been detected even
though the other three particle kinds of
particles have all been detected and
even though we know that gravity works
so there ought to be a graviton
gravitons have never been found
and so this is the point where we can
now speculate from real science into
science fiction that's what Star Trek is
basing its what's it I think it's
interesting that they've taken something
like that that's in the realm of theory
and they've moved it forward is it is it
possible to move forward from here we
don't know but they have applied that
yes this wonderful adventure it's really
nice so summer gravitons for artificial
gravity or for warp drive what do you
think I don't know okay but it's like I
mean we we knew that the Higgs boson
existed or in theory we theorized that
it existed and we had to build massive
massive machines to attempt to just find
a hint of it so maybe we'll just
continue to do that and hopefully we'll
have another international international
collaboration that will come together to
find evidence of the graviton wonderful
thank you thank you very much yes well I
have several questions okay pick one oh
just one of for now yes
well do one second okay well all the
questions were good but I'll do
just do one this time do more next time
okay they've been doing research about
how how possible is the warp drive yes
it wasn't using me and that's I know
that stuff mm-hmm
what are the latest news about that is
it's still like something that's fantasy
or is it gonna be real but anyone know
the latest information from NASA the
last I heard was it is still fantasy but
nevertheless there is some theoretical
framework that as summer has
demonstrated earlier that there is a
possibility of warping space and time so
now it's just a matter of whether we can
warp it for our needs those
gravitational waves that summer was
talking about earlier where space at
time was literally rippling because of
the collision of two supermassive black
holes those ripples which were less than
the width of a proton over a multi mile
stretch in order to have created that
much energy to ripple across space-time
it would have been like having our Sun
use its entire energy output that it
would have shined over ten billion years
in less than a tenth of a second so if
we can control that amount of energy
than yes warp drive is very very
possible would that be nice 2020 sure
let's stick it on to NASA's to Cadle
survey planets let's do it yes go ahead
thank you for your question hi everybody
hello it's my first Star Trek on ever
alright alright can I do a two-part
question not if you want to piss that
die off go ahead and do two parts that
are really close to one another
all right how does do one alright this
is one thing about is one thing that you
know I love Star Trek my whole life but
one thing about it just hit me a couple
weeks ago and it actually happened when
I wasn't watching Star Trek at all
actually watching Man of Steel you ever
see man is steel when Superman arrives
on the Kryptonian ship that blown to Zod
and he's nagging and children is not
used to the atmosphere but all
stuff tell me more it got me know it got
me thinking all right
every crew in Star Trek goes on all
these different planets they can't all
have the same type of oxygen and
atmosphere and things like that for
humans to breathe especially not Kronos
you see how dirty Kronos is my bad
that woman is from Kronos assaulted her
much loved the Klingons I'll bet you
don't like Klingon opera either so I
gotta tell you that was an opera that's
not too bad so easy a little rusty well
like do they ever explain how human
beings could breathe these so really I
think the better question is can you
classify how they determine planets like
Earth being a class-m planet and the
other planets being different classes
because that's really what he's talking
about because clearly there only beaming
down to class-m planets so how is that
determination made yeah well I think
right you're right like in the Star Trek
lower there are those classifications of
the ones that have the breathable
atmosphere and so in theory I think to
some extent it's very possible that
there are millions of planets in
habitable zones because there's a
hundred billion stars in the Milky Way
galaxy that's true and if in theory
we're finding you know potentially
statistically says every plane it could
have every star could have a planet so
out of 100 billion you could easily have
a million and that doesn't even exhaust
the ones that they've been to and all of
these you could easily have a hundred
million yeah out of a hundred billion
yeah and the elements to that we're
talking about like we've discovering
water is ubiquitous throughout the
universe we're finding them in nebulas
we're finding them all over the place
and very unusual play very distant yeah
even other galaxies so I guess the
answer is although it is impossible that
every planet has such breathable
atmosphere
it is possible that there are enough
breathable atmosphere planets that we
actually can just fill 17 seasons of
different Star Trek episodes that's a
great question thank you
that doesn't make make the whole thing
does make so much more sense thank you
guys you're welcome
and sir and the final question yeah so
this is a practical question but I want
you to like give me an estimate
hypothesize a little bit about it the
core of Earth and by extension of any
extrasolar planet that still has an
active core radiates right there is
radioactive decay is it possible for us
in the future this is not too much of a
Star Trek question for us to build
sensitive enough radio telescopes so
that we can detect extrasolar planets
that way hmm
so instead of using transit or effects
or direct imaging can we use radar I
guess that the elements that decay in
the core are different from what you
would get from stars you know yeah a
resident radio astronomer some theory
that sounds to me like that would be
something that would work but I would
think potentially it's the resolution of
the radio because that would be such a
small source and like I said stars will
emit from the radio so it's how
sensitive can you get your instruments
to detect a difference from what you
would expect from the star but they
already are looking for planets also
within an infrared because basically you
can see the heat signature of a planet
reradiating the heat that it's absorbed
from its star and so in theory I think
then the next step would potentially be
that but it's just going to take a you
know a huge leap forward in our
technology so all you have to do now is
invent that equipment and you get your
Nobel Prize
you're gonna be my partner gonna have
three of them well this has been such a
wonderful opportunity here to talk with
you all to geek out just a little tiny
bit but also bring some science down to
earth and to our kitchens into our homes
here into New York I think it's fair to
say that this is the very very best
starch Star Trek emissions panel that I
have ever ever moderated and hosted so I
want to thank you all very very much
Chuck nice my co-host thank you so much
for being some pleasure you guys are
amazing thank you each and every one of
you for coming out and spending time
with us and Rufus akos author of the
book star trek the official guide the
universe thank you so so much for being
part of this wonderful thing coming down
from Canada for this summer ash my
friend thank you so much hearing you on
Startalk all-stars and this is the book
star talk with Neil deGrasse Tyson which
is available down there if you want to
go find it please do or otherwise this
is Startalk Allstars
a live episode thank you all for being
part of it I'm Charles Lou enjoy the
universe everyone thank you so much this
is Startalk
you
[Music]